you see when you ask why something
happens how does a person answer why
something happens for example aunt
Minnie is in the hospital why because
she went out and she slipped on the ice
and broke her hip that satisfies it
people but it wouldn't satisfy someone
who came from another planet knew
nothing about the freshers understand
why when you break your hip do you go to
the hospital how do you get to the
hospital with the window hip is broken
well because her husband seeing that she
had the hip with book and call the
hospital up and sent somebody to get her
all that is understood by people and
when you explain it a why you have to be
in some framework that you allow
something to be true otherwise you're
perpetually asking why why did the
husband call up the hospital because
husband is interested in his wife's
welfare not always some husbands aren't
interested they're wise well for they're
drunk and they're angry and so you begin
to get a very interesting understanding
of the world and all its complications
and Northey if you try to follow
anything up you go deeper and deeper in
various directions
if for example you go why did she slip
on the ice will Isis slippery everybody
knows that no problem but yes why is ice
slippery that's kind of curious ice is
extremely slippery it's very interesting
you see so you could either say I'm
satisfied that you've answered me ice is
slippery that explains it or you could
go out and say why is ice slippery and
then you're involved with something
because there aren't many things as
slippery as ice it's very hard to get
grease but that's sort of wet slimy but
a solid that's so slippery because it is
in the case of ice that when you stand
on it they say momentarily the pressure
melts the ice a little bit so you got a
sort of instantaneous water surface on
which you're slipping why aren't ice are
not on other things because water
expands when it freezes so the pressure
tries to undo the expansion and melts it
is capable of melting it but other
substances cracked when they're freezing
and when you push images to satisfied to
be solid
why does water expand when it freezes
and other substance don't expand when
they freeze all right I'm I'm not
answering your question but I'm telling
you how difficult the why question is
you have to know what it is that you're
permitted to understand and allow to be
understood and known and what it is
you're not you'll notice in this example
that the more I ask why it gets
interesting afterwards my idea that the
deeper thing is the more interesting it
we could even go further and say why did
she fall down when she slipped that has
to do with grabbing involves in all the
planets of everything else never mind it
goes on and on
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder